You may have noticed the shimmering colors
soap bubbles produce
the last time you washed the dishes
This iridescence is the result of light bouncing
around through the bubbles --
also found in bird feathers as structural color--
microscopic surface features
that control the reflection of light.
Normally, structural colors are hard to use as pigments
because they are iridescent--
meaning they don’t appear the same
from all angles or are not very saturated.
Now researchers have created a new
biocompatible structural color
that can produce saturated colors that don’t iridesce.
It all starts with a synthetic version of
melanin,
a biological pigment
found all throughout the natural world
It determines the color of your hair, your skin,
and even your eyes
First the researchers took synthetic melanin particles,
coated them in a shell made of silica
and immersed them into water.
Silica -- also known as silicon dioxide --
is sometimes used in food production.
Droplets of this particle-infused water
were then added to an oil emulsion.
As the water separated from the oil,
the melanin particles left behind
self-assembled into micron-sized “supraballs”.
Once the oil is removed,
all that is left is a colorful powder
that can be used anywhere
that conventional pigments are used.
The color can be tuned by varying the thickness
of the silica shell around the melanin core.
Thicker shells increase the space between the melanin particles,
which, in turn, produce different colors
Different supraballs can be mixed together
to obtain even more colors.
Unlike conventional dyes and pigments,
the powder is resistant to UV radiation,
so it won’t fade in the sun.
And since the particles are made of melanin,
the colors are biocompatible and can be used
in food dyes, cosmetics and even tattoo ink.
Researchers also hope to design mathematical models
for color combinations that will build
out the color space for these structural colors.